they're great stand-ups i've seen a
bunch of them where it's the
same thing every
time and you don't work that way i don't
work that way man because i feel i
perform for the audience that's in front
of me
i i don't i hate being robotic being
robotic is the worst
see it's robotic is horrible uh on stage
and horrible in the [ __ ] bed oh [ __ ]
nothing worse than a [ __ ] robot in
bed
wait a minute sex robots are a big thing
right now bro it's like a big business
i think you got it all wrong no no i'm
talking about
being you being a [ __ ] robot well
that wouldn't be good you
you're the robot you know what i'm
saying and that's
twofold if you're a [ __ ] robot in bed
and you [ __ ] a robot too in bed
see you that's counterproductive yeah
two robots in bed
is one robot too many in bed that's one
robot two [ __ ] minute
see it might get interesting if you
throw a regular person in there and have
a
three-way one normal person and two or
two [ __ ] robots
see more barbarians you're spending too
much time with her
i'm jealous now my regret this decision
the execution is wearing off reaping
[ __ ] robots short circuit and [ __ ]
and you know start sparking and [ __ ] you
know that be careful
with [ __ ] robots anyway but but see
i hate being robotic on stage i love to
perform for the moment because
that means this audience in front of you
is going to get something that the next
audience is not going to get